Silicon Valley your character Jared
they've introduced they introduced these
great touches about about him he's such
a sweet guy and and and and
mild-mannered but they added this
element that he screams in his sleep in
German yeah why did they add that where
did that come from
okay well that's bait that's based on me
and I always want him prefaced like
whenever I explained this to anyone I
always like to say I'm Jewish I my whole
family's Jewish I'm big fan of the
Jewish people being one myself yes you
you you are a Jewish man I'm a Jewish
man so bear that in mind but when I was
in in college one night I went to bed
early and my roommate stayed up because
he was writing a paper and the next
morning I woke up and my roommate was
looking at me and he was like are you
okay and and I was like well what do you
mean yeah I'm fine
and he said last night you went to bed
and I was up writing and in the middle
of the night you sat up bolt upright
made eye contact with me and said I hate
the Jews
what I don't know
no so is this some inner self loathing
what is of like a nocturnal anti-sea
yeah so I told Alec Berg
yeah producer that show and he and I
think that was the basis for the German
shrieking that you just shriek German
yeah yeah
you